okay we're all distraught right we're
distraught over incoming president
donald trump it's understandable after
george w bush's reelection i actually
tried telling myself hey i'm just gonna
like george w bush he's a patriot just
embrace the guy just like it life would
have been so much easier for me if I
just said hey you know what all this
stuff about John Kerry and Al Gore just
embrace george w bush life will be
easier but i couldn't do it because it
just made no sense to me and i'm not
going to be able to do it under
President Trump and we already did the
blame game earlier it wasn't third
parties it wasn't Jill Stein it was the
media somewhat but only to the extent
that there weren't enough alternatives
to corporate media during this race
racist ideas were uh basically a planted
in the Republican Party for the last 20
years Donald Trump coalesce those ideas
and got those people to feel like hey
this stuff that has been sort of quietly
bringing me into the Republican Party
over time now Donald Trump actually
embodies it we can blame that but we
can't control who the Republican select
during their primary we can't control
whether right wingers are racist or like
racist ideas but we can control or we
should be able to control who the
Democrat Democratic candidate is as well
as voter turnout turnout was not high
enough the candidate was the wrong
candidate as I said so now let's lay out
the next six years the next six years
are going to be make or break number one
in two years we have midterm elections
all 435 House seats are up for
reelection again but we will still be
totally gerrymandered in favor of
Republicans in 2018 more on that later
33 of 100 Senate seats will be up for
reelection and in addition to that there
will be 38 state and territorial
governorships and numerous other state
and local elections that will be
contested just as an example I will show
you the UH governorships that will be up
for uh uh potential reelection so you
see that in alabama robert bentley will
be term-limited for 2018 you see that
Jerry Brown will be term limited in 2018
as will the Colorado Democratic governor
but both Florida and Georgia governor
rick scott and nathan Deal will be term
limited
and there are a lot of red governor's
houses including in Idaho in Illinois in
uh where else uh Kansas and Maine
Michigan Nevada New Mexico Ohio Oklahoma
will we have either retiring or
term-limited Republicans South Carolina
and South Dakota and Tennessee and
Wyoming now a lot of these are not going
to be easy for Democrats to win but that
is a big opportunity in 2018 that gets
us to 2020 we have the 2020 election for
a new president another 33 senate seats
and this is where it really get it gets
interesting and this comes to
gerrymandering 2020 will have a census
and after that census we will have
another redrawing of congressional
districts we've talked about the Trump
election having generational impact
through the Supreme Court I'm not
waiting until August of twenty20 to
start explaining to you that the next
three cycles are huge take control of
the Senate in 2018 it starts now and
today it's november 9 2016 that has to
start now white house in 2012 have to
win it back governor's mansions in 2018
and 2020 new census in 2020 redraw the
districts in a way that is not obviously
gerrymandered for republicans if we can
make inroads in the governor's senate
house and then maybe you could actually
win the house in 2022 i I know that it's
only November ninth but this is how it
has to be we have to start working on
this right now well I'm really concerned
about the 2018 midterm elections yeah
because Democrats have to hold court in
Indiana Montana Missouri North Dakota
North Dakota West Virginia user states
that they currently have a Democratic
senator and and they're all red states
so it's really unlikely that they're
gonna take control back of the Senate in
the next go around and we know that
first presidential term midterms are
really not great for Democrats Rachel so
we're already sort of at a disadvantage
here but this is it you know but
progressives they get very activated in
the year before presidential election
now is the time to do the work and I
know that it's just boring for some
people but you've got to do the work and
publicans do it at the local level they
do I was just thinking also about the
Rust Belt states because they've now
been voting for republicans in the past
how many so years so how is that going
to affect it ya know that will that will
be absolutely an issue and we saw you
know presidentially a lot of those
states often go blue but they have such
a Republican infrastructure this is a
big task but this is the path forward
and we're going to be here with you for
it and we'll keep talking about it